(solemn music)
- [Voiceover] Dear Mom,
these are the flowers
I would have bought you
and this is the card I
would have written you.
I've spent most of my life
trying to fill in the blanks.
Asking everyone around me about you.
The memories of you tucked
away in a box in the attic.
I don't remember what
your perfume smelled like,
or what made you laugh,
but I'll never forget
lying in your hospital bed
drawing pictures with you.
Your rebellious little six year old.
I'm writing this because I wanna tell you
that you were so strong.
That I wish you didn't have
to look at your daughter
knowing that you'd never
see her get taller,
get heartbroken, get married.
I'm sorry that I always
made you pick me up
when you were so weak.
That I tripped over your IV pole.
The Christmas I complained that
I didn't get what I wanted.
Being afraid of your wig.
I'm sorry for the fits I threw,
the I love you moms I never got to say.
And I'm sorry that it's taken me 21 years
to write this card, and
it's still not perfect.
I'm writing this because I'd give anything
just to be able to fight with you.
I never got to ignore your phone calls
because you were too overbearing.
I never got to introduce
you to girlfriends
or boyfriends you say are bad for me,
and I tell you that you don't understand,
but months later I realize
that you were right.
I'm writing this because I'm angry
that I have to live life only part way.
All the yearbook pictures I took
without you to do my hair,
the lunches I made myself.
I feel like I'm missing out on
a huge part of being a woman
because you're not here.
Like a part of me is in
that coffin with you,
holding onto your leg,
while I scoot across the
floor begging you not to go.
You were so beautiful.
It's insane to believe that anyone
as beautiful as you ever
existed on this earth.
I'm writing this because
I wish you were here,
I wish you could see the
woman that I've grown into.
I wish I knew which flowers you liked
and that I could put them in your hands,
rather than on a plot of
grass with your name on it.
I'm writing this because
I wanna say thank you.
No matter how sick you
were all you wanted to do
was make sure I felt loved.
Thank you for taking me to Disney World
when you were in a wheelchair,
letting me draw those
pictures in your hospital bed,
writing me letters like you knew
I'd grow up to be who I am.
Making me feel like I was
so special and so smart.
I feel like I'll always
be that six year old
with a mind of her own,
that didn't take orders
and doesn't wear dresses.
That's still waiting
for her mom to wake up
and tell her that
everything is okay again.
I'm writing this because
I'll never love anyone
as much as I miss you.
Happy Mother's Day.